[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing a segment
from the Deathly Hallows involving Draco
Malfoy and Harry Potter more
specifically we'll be addressing the
moment that Draco Malfoy fails to
identify Harry Potter in the presence of
his father and fellow Death Eaters what
I want to explore is why did Draco
simply fail to recognize Harry was it an
act of
self-preservation or was this draco's
chance at some form of redemption let's
dive in it all begins on chapter 23 of
the Deathly Hallows Malfoy Mana where
there is some confusion around Harry's
identity now let's see who we've got
said greybacks gloating voice from
overhead and Harry was rolled over onto
his back a beam of one light fell onto
his face and gryback laughed I'll be
needing butterbeer to wash this one down
what happened to you ugly Harry did not
answer immediately I said repeated
greyback and Harry received a blow to
the diaphragm that made him double over
in pain what happened to you stung Harry
muttered been stung yeah looks like it
said a second voice what's your name
snarled greyback Dudley said Harry and
your first name I Vernon Vernon Dudley
and why was Harry so
unrecognizable well just before being
captured by the snatchers herione smart
as always was able to fire a stinging
Jinx directly into Harry's face the
resulting swelling disfigured his face
so much that he was no longer
recognizable however despite Hermione's
quick thinking in her attempt to make
Harry unrecognizable there were still
things that allowed Harry to be easily
identified like his scar and signature
glasses what's that on your forehead
Vernon he asked softly his breath foul
in Harry's nostrils as he pressed a
filthy finger to the tort scar don't
touch it Harry yel he could not stop
himself he thought he might be sick from
the pain of it I thought you wore
glasses Potter breathed greyback I found
glasses yelped one of the snatchers
skullking in the background there was
glasses in the tent Grayback wait and
seconds later Harry's glasses had been
rammed back onto his face the snatchers
were closing in now peering at him it is
rasped greyback we've caught Potter but
while the snatchers were entirely
confident in identifying Harry
ultimately the decision to identify
Harry in advance of alerting the dark
lord fell on Draco as he knew him best
they say they've got Potter said ncis's
cold voice Draco come here well Draco
said lucius's Malfoy he sounded Avid is
it is it Harry Potter I can't I can't be
sure said Draco he was keeping his
distance from greyback and seemed as
scared of looking at Harry as Harry was
of looking at him but look at him
carefully look come closer Harry had
never heard luci's mouth voice so
excited there's something there he
whispered it could be the scar stretched
tight Draco come here look properly what
do you think Harry saw draco's face up
close now right beside his father's they
were extraordinarily alike except that
while his father looked beside himself
with excitement draco's expression was
full of reluctance even fear I don't
know he said and he walked away towards
the fireplace where his mother stood
watching In This Moment Draco could have
changed the fate of The Wizarding World
entirely he could have redeemed his
family name brought honor at least in
the eyes of Voldemort back to his father
become a star among the Death Eaters and
secured Voldemort's rise to power what
led to his inaction I've got a few
different answers for why this happened
the first possibility that I want to
explore is in my view the least likely
that draco's inaction was solely the
result of his own desire for
self-preservation as unlikely as it is
there's always the possibility that
Draco was simply not 100% sure that this
disfigured swollen boy was Harry in this
instance draco's inability to identify
Harry would have stemmed from his fear
of misidentifying Harry if drao did
indeed confirm that this figure was
Harry and then Voldemort was called only
to find out that this was not Harry
after all then things would have only
gotten worse for him and his family in
the books even Harry admits that he
wouldn't have recognized himself Harry
was facing a mirror over the fireplace a
great gilded thing in an intricately
scrolled frame through the slits of his
eyes he saw his own reflection for the
first time since leaving grimmel place
his face was huge shiny and pink every
feature distorted by her's Jinx his
black hair reached his shoulders and
there was a dark shadow around his jaw
had he not known that it was he who
stood there he would have wondered who
was wearing his glasses he resolved not
to speak for his voice was sure to give
him away yet he still avoided eye
contact with Draco as the latter
approached but do I think that this was
what led to draco's inaction probably
not the next possibility I want to
discuss is that Draco despite being a
subscriber to the ideologies of the
death heaters simply didn't want to put
his childhood acquaintances In Harm's
Way Draco knew that if if he turned over
Harry it would have meant the end for
Harry Ron and herione though Draco
loathed these three or at least his
previous actions would lead us to
believe he did he didn't want to be the
cause of their deaths did he want glory
for his family yes did he want deathy to
rule maybe but he didn't want any of
this at the cost of his old classmates
lives the next and most likely
possibility that I want to discuss is
that Draco no longer subscribed to the
ideologies of the death heaters at all
he may have always talked the talk but
wasn't willing to walk the walk the
events of the halfblood prince had taken
their toll on Draco and the perpetually
sneering boy that had always exuded some
sort of false confidence had started to
become a nervous wreck after being
tasked with killing his school head
Master while we began to witness his
downfall after being given his Dubious
Task near the beginning it wasn't until
the end of the book and Dumbledore's
death that we saw Draco reduced to
someone so unlike his former self seeing
death Dumbledore being struck down at
top the astronomy Tower and charity
Burbage being tortured and killed in her
own home had forced Draco to recognize
his own ignorance we also have to
remember that it was Draco who set those
Wheels in Motion by allowing Death
Eaters to infiltrate Hogwarts via the
Vanishing cabinet it's likely that Draco
took responsibility for Dumbledore's
death hated the feeling and wanted to
avoid having any more blood on his hands
Draco who uttered horrible slurs for
basically his entire childhood was
simply echoing the voice of his father
Draco didn't really hate muggle borns or
blood traitors he was just ignorant and
too young and unwise to recognize
otherwise after witnessing death for the
first time dra recognized that there was
a distinct difference between snaring
insults and condemning his old
classmates to a long painful and
publicized death expanding on this it's
possible that Draco simply began to
imagine what a future under Voldemort's
rule might look like just a few years
prior Draco didn't have a care in the
world but now he was torturing Death
Eaters for Voldemort watching his
professors get murdered and watching his
father who he so looked at to get
belittled and marginalized by the man
who was meant to be the new ruler of the
Wizarding World it wasn't a game anymore
and the dark mark on his arm reminded
him of every moment he spent awake in
the nightmare that his life had become
identifying Harry would have eliminated
the one chance he had of Life returning
to normal Another Thing Worth looking at
is that Draco said I don't know not no
what does this mean in in my opinion
Draco failing to outright deny that this
unidentified figure was Harry was never
representative of him wishing harm upon
his old schoolmate his indecision was
simply the product of his mind weighing
the path that he had taken with the path
that he now needed to take despite
recognizing what course of action he
would now need to take he couldn't quite
vocalize his commitment to it and that's
why he ended up settling for a passive I
don't know the last question that needs
to be answered on this topic is why on
Earth draco's father Lucius wasn't able
to recognize Harry Lucius had met Harry
on multiple occasions and he knew who
Harry hung out with in the Chamber of
Secrets he mentions to herione that
Draco told him all about her and even
points out Ron's red hair and it's not
like Harry's iconic scar was some big
secret Lucia's comments on Harry's scar
earlier in the series forgive me your
scar is Legend what's the deal here
here's the thing he probably did but
without absolute certainty calling
Voldemort would have been a very poor
decision especially if it turned out not
to be Harry Lucius was already in
Voldemort's bad books and wasting his
time further would have been very very
bad for him and his family they needed
confirmation that it was Harry without
any shred of doubt and Draco would have
been the only one to provide that
however as we know that's not quite how
things panned out and that's it for this
video did you ever Ponder draco's
indecision In This Moment did I hit the
nail on the head here or is there
something I've missed leave a comment
down below also if you enjoy the content
it helps me a lot if you like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to
[Music]
live